one i see propaganda all the time
talking about how like women over 40 are
super happy like i see this all the time
like oh it's okay to be alone never
settle da da da like i see the opposite
propaganda honestly and on top of that
like
women 45 single and childless are the
least happy demographic i i just don't
know how you prove that no no because
they survey people
they serve it they certainly this is
this is what this is what i mean like i
know no i'm not like the same but it
just seems so general and it just seems
like i i just like pulling we're
biologically programmed to want children
yeah i would not naturally everybody
you're right not everybody is but the
majority of us are and typically when i
see a woman that doesn't want kids like
she somehow was hurt in the past and
that's why she doesn't it's like i think
i start out i think every woman starts
her life out wanting a family and kids
and then at some point society gets in
her head or bad experiences get in her
head and that warps that the woman that
says she doesn't want kids is just as
much of an outlier as a man that says he
doesn't want to cheat